[Music]
you are so openhearted you exhaust other
people what are you more excited about
winning the gold or losing the
vCard yo mama oh what's the Stitch
downstairs crabs on crabs on crabs on
crab you have a very ornate
vagina nobody tells me what to do I
could push a button and get another host
in here right away they're like Dixie
Cups you pull one out another one drops
down pal what is a
motorcycle made of
tubes I'm going to kick your ass Phil
can I guarantee that I'll do it I'll do
it I'll do it I'll do it super jerk I
can be your hero welcome to the tea pure
L drink it Cherry boy that's a wrap on
[Music]
me PE
show is the
best
show in
the
[Music]
land